help us change the culture by buying our
latest single from tim cast records only
ever wanted by clicking the link in the
description below
from timcast.com
sandy hook families ask judge to remove
alex jones from control of his company
now i don't mean to say this story
literally specifically is democratic
operatives trying to cheat what i'm
saying is
the things we have seen levied at alex
jones in general
are destroying his ability to run his
company
and
along with many other people the
censorship ramped up tremendously in
2018
and is still persistent with now the
revelation that the fbi made a request
to to facebook and then facebook was
like oh we better censor this hunter
button laptop stuff
the moves made against donald trump the
moves made to censor stories the the the
destruction of alex jones in in force
and all that stuff and for all of the
things you can criticize them for i get
it i get it the fact is they're going
after speech this would not be necessary
if they were winning
they wouldn't need to go after alex
jones unless alex jones is actually a
threat to the establishment just saying
his name is giving him publicity that's
right
what's happening now is in the lawsuit
the families are alleging that he's
funneling money to uh free speech
systems his company is funneling money
to a family member i say according to
the motion
free speech systems claims to owe a
massive secure debt to an insider that
was first reported when the cases
against jones began
but no records show that debt existed
prior to the lawsuit attorneys for the
families are now requesting a bankruptcy
trustee assume control of his company
they have also requested the court
appoint a tort claimant's committee to
investigate free speech systems business
dealings and for the court to remove fss
as the debtor in possession
this is kind of crazy
because people talked about this
when uh jones lost his lawsuit or i
shouldn't say when he lost it he was in
default but when he was sentenced to pay
you know 45 45 million or whatever 50
million
imagine
you uh cut a deal with someone legit
then they get sued
or let's say they're they're getting
sued and you don't know and you do a
deal with them now the court's coming
after you and they're going to take from
you because of something he did how is
that legal that to me is crazy i would
think that that would not be that's what
they're doing they're basically saying
that the other people who who owes money
to is illegitimate and should be
basically suspended
that's kind of crazy isn't it
desperation
this is what i think well look the
families are asking it and i think that
has a lot to do with they want the money
that they sued him over and if he's
broke ain't no money to get so this is
the course they take but my point is you
are seeing a lot of stuff launched at
alex jones you are seeing a lot of stuff
launched in a ton of people and it's
going to get crazier you think the
midterms are crazy it's like we're a
couple months out and it's getting nuts
they raided a former president's home
unprecedented imagine 2023 2024 it's
almost like they're throwing
spaghetti at a wall because they're
hoping some of it will stick that's
exactly what it feels like to me and it
does look like desperation like they're
getting crazy this is this is how you
know when your spaghetti is done you
guys know this right you throw it at the
wall you pull out a thing you throw it
at the wall if it sticks good i'm just
start doing that
you know what's good about saying alex
jones type of person not to speak for
him or anything but a lot of people on
the right are
people of faith let's say you get a
marjorie taylor green or something like
that
they are trained because of their faith
too
we are
it's like we're conditioned to suffer
and take it
and that's when the qualities of the
right shine the most is when you're
oppressing them and it's like wait why
aren't you staying down why do you keep
getting up and it's like no i actually
kind of love this
i think that oh
no it's just they worship a guy whose
whole shtick is he was beaten to death
and then he came back to life so it's
like the more you oppress say a
christian or something like that
judeo-christian perhaps
the more they're like oh wait i'm
actually more in alignment with the
person who i'm supposed to be emulating
i find it's a psyop i think that the
catholic church on purpose made people
believe that they're supposed to suffer
and that they're bad so that they would
become servants to the church okay so
this is actually something that victor
frankel observed in his time and fidor
dostoevsky also observed it in his time
in concentration camp in soviet russia
he observed that people who followed
religions were impossible to stop you
could not keep them down they firmly
believed they were following what was
true and i think that's and i can you i
can obviously prove that that's 100
divorced from the church it had nothing
to do with the church this was something
that they held inside themselves they're
taught scripturally exactly this is what
like the hardcore disciples and say the
book of acts or something yeah you're
the most in alignment you're the closest
to being like the disciples who like
they're like no please torturing me more
so that my resurrection is better yeah
saint paul has said something like that
where it's like i want to have an even
more even uh i don't know i want to get
more buff points or something when when
i level up and when i was yeah no
because at the very core of what they
believe is that i mean they don't talk
about this very often and maybe i'm
going on a tangent but
at the core of christianity is you
expect to be resurrected so even if
you're thrown to the lions literally in
early biblical times
tortured to death whatever that actually
brings you closer to
um
it's kind of like you you if you're not
being tortured maybe you're doing
something wrong right in fact in
revelation one of the things they were
talking about was how god despised the
lukewarm church he's like you were in
either hot nor cold and for that reason
i spit you out of my mouth you're just
kind of there yeah you're just there but
i was talking about this the other day
and well i'm not going to apologize but
uh
talking about lukewarm christians and
that sort of thing and um even with the
vaccine mandates and you weren't allowed
to go to church or any of that stuff
i would still hear stories about people
going to church and meeting anyway even
though the state told them they weren't
allowed to yeah it's like that's where
you find where the lukewarm christians
were is the ones who kind of just like
oh i'll do whatever the state tells me
to it's like no actually in the early
church again we were meeting underground
when you could be found and killed you
know you remember i don't know
you know the origin of the jesus fish i
was gonna say that that's what i was
gonna say yeah one person would would
draw an uh a crescent and then the other
person would finish it creating the
shape of a fish secret message so that
you knew we are fishers of men yeah
but that's i mean honestly that's when
you you feel the heat of your faith
really is when you can die for it but
you still believe it anyway so i have
family members who are so
not to say too much out of respect but
like i know one that uh
was facing their death let's say or is
facing their death and that is when they
are the most themselves and everyone's
like how are you holding it together and
it's like no i'm going to go see jesus
soon yeah yeah they
so again i'm complimenting christians in
the sense of like the more you push them
the more you force them to like hey
we're going to be mean to you and we're
going to dox you or we're going to swat
you bring it they love it and actually i
don't know if the left understands this
because maybe they don't believe
anything i think they don't really
believe in christianity because they
dismiss it sort of out right uh but like
throughout the christian bible they're
the reminders of like uh set your mind
all the things above i think there's a
verse in colossians about that where
it's a constant reminder that like
what's happening on earth is not your
ultimate end goal and i think if you
aren't a person of faith that's very
difficult to embrace because like the
idea of eternity and the consequences of
your actions here you know for some
people this is all you have and so you
have to do whatever like whatever your
ultimate ideology is you have to pursue
it intensely whereas christians aren't
driven that way
i want to address you know you you were
mentioning about getting backed into a
corner and then you know what you're
talking about did you say a rat or what
you say just like no just if i'm forced
to retreat eventually there's going to
be a cliff behind me you know what i was
thinking you guys see that video of the
lady being attacked by the rabid fox
yeah what the heck was that that made me
feel like the summer of love like the
analogy it's like you're sitting there
minding your own business you're
watering your lawn and a rabid fox just
runs up and attacks you for no reason
and you try and kick it off but it keeps
biting you then it bites onto her hand
and she's like swinging it around and
then throws it and then she's got a gash
and she got puncture wounds then she's
got to get the rabies shot and it's like
man she didn't even do anything to
anybody right that's how it felt with
like the blm riots so a lot of people
talk about how yet you know someone
super chatted the establishment is
losing but a cornered rat bites the
hardest and i'm like you got two choices
you can go and water your flowers and
mind your own business and the rabbit
fox attacks you or you can be proactive
and chase it off with the hose because
they're hydrophobic and then it might
get into a corner and freak out but what
do you choose do you choose to say i'm
not going to allow you to come under my
house or you say i'm just going to go
over here and ignore you and then you're
eventually going to bite me yeah i think
being proactive and saying no just
saying no standing up
even if it means you know you're backing
backing the establishment that's that's
the problem i have i do believe that the
faith in god or in a perception and
something greater than the physical
experience that we're having is
important and it gives me faith in
saying what i believe regardless of
consequences often but the feeling of
being okay to be a servant is disturbing
to me because i think that's church
propaganda that they want people to be
subservient so that they don't rise up
and overthrow corrupt corrupt
governments and systems and
i i don't like seeing people back into
corner i don't like seeing people act
out of fear i don't think they should
have to and if you're proactive you
don't have to because you put yourself
in a position of stability
here's what everyone's got to do
when someone's being mean to you on
twitter respond by just being nice even
if it if you don't want to
swallow your pride all right swallow
your pride
all right and then when someone says
something nasty to you just say
something nice back and leave it at that
choke on the rind
i don't know what that means but feel it
keep it empty
[Laughter]
sweet lyrics my favorite uh i mean quite
literally like a lot of it a lot of
people will be like i'm not this person
slighted me i'm not going to and i'm
saying yes while you're pride it means
like don't
stand up and be like i refuse to accept
no no you have to accept that in in
strategy and and being being a tactician
requires winning
winning is not
someone insults you so he insult him
back all you're doing is flinging mud if
you really want to win someone insults
you you be nice to them
and completely stop the fight the fight
you win is the fight you don't engage in
so that's what that's what i'm saying
well an interesting thing also to
consider uh to add to what you were
saying ian is uh at the bottom level or
the top level of christianity like i
don't think a lot of them practicing
understand how crazy this is like they
actually think that they will be
resurrected like actually
and not in an abstract way they mean
like bodily like in x thousand years
yeah but i'm not sure
a lot of people probably don't believe
it or it's too crazy i think that when i
talk to
the learned
religious folk they don't say stuff like
that it's too weird but it's that
interesting because there's the thing of
if you're a servant and you let yourself
be controlled now
later you'll be a king and you're like
that's just a manipulation manipulation
tactic to get people to serve i believe
one could say that i mean biblically
speaking you could one could try to
argue that that those verses were added
later on down the road like when you
look at the different um
manuscript translations and they have
found a lot of old manuscripts that are
super super close to when the disciples
had written most of the new testament
the apostle
and
it's pretty much
they have not changed very much yeah
consciousness dude is going to rise your
spirit is alive and active or maybe not
alive in the sense of our bodies but
it's it's a it's a
momentous organism you could say it's
not of course it's not an organism it's
not carbon-based but
whether you're a slave in life or you're
a hero in life your soul is still going
to live on it's still going to be there
after well in that sense too like you
could just say the christian is
embodying what jesus did by
jesus still lives on through them by
them continuing what he said and
basically promised so when and to go
back to why an american would stand
their ground and why we love standing
our ground culturally
we are certain that by doing that the
next generations who inherit america
from us
are going to benefit by copying that
behavior i'm going to stand my ground
and not retreat and that will probably
end up preserving the country as opposed
to if i keep backing away and ceding
ground to enemies who keep trying to
push me
they will
they don't even have to fight me and
they'll win the ground but if i stand my
ground and force them to fight and
engage me
it's going to get ugly and maybe it's
going to cost them more than they want
to pay
and
i'm sorry go ahead no i'm just and
forcing people to take you know they say
turn the other cheek it's like no i am
in fact willing to let you hit me and
i'm daring you now to hurt me even more
because eventually that will make me win
by default you are the aggressor you
lose like look what happened to rome it
became christian because they kept it
was originally a secret religion and you
were killed for believing it but
eventually it became the religion of
rome because among other reasons they
were persecuting them so hard everybody
became a christian
so i think about this with the raid on
donald trump and it looks like they're
trying to indict him on something i said
it before a lot of world leaders
historical leaders good and bad
the persecution led them to rise to
power yeah good leaders that we like
industry and bad leaders we don't like
in history you know making someone into
a political martyr doesn't tend to work
out for their enemies it makes yeah it
makes you look like
hey why are you being mean to him i'm
going to go support him i want to
support the under i think that's why
this like attempted complete decimation
of alex jones at infowars as a whole is
miscalculated i think there is like
if you are part of sandy hook families
it's much more emotional i think there
are politics behind it but of course
there's it's more complicated
but i think
ultimately they need alex jones to not
become a martyr so they need a complete
wipeout they can't leave any remnants of
what he's left behind because of one in
a lot of ways he was a huge he was a
gateway for a lot of people to become
supportive of donald trump and they
can't have that again i think it was
james lindsay who mentioned on the show
that he was like on a plane with a woman
and then she said that she didn't like
trump but this raid against him was was
was wrong and it was a step too far
right they shocked the system hard
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there's a massive library to
check out so again go to timcast.com or
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
we'll see you all there